we have been working very hard since
Monday morning to come to an agreement
on the 2018 catch limits for the main
commercial fish stocks in the EU waters
and for EU fishing vessels in non EU
waters the negotiations have been
difficult but I am very pleased to
announce that the council has arrived at
a unanimous agreement with just one
member state abstaining we paid
particular attention to the European
Eagle stock which as you know is in a
critical condition all the Member States
committed to improve implementation of
the real management plans we are also
making additional efforts to protect sea
bass a very important stock for many
countries for the first time at a low
level
we agreed to close eel fisheries for
three months during their migration
period
moreover Member States committed two
additional actions to protect the Eels
throughout its lifecycle and in all sea
basins today we agreed on fishing
opportunities worth over five billion
euros benefiting more than 50 thousand
fishermen as a result of responsible
decisions in the last year's the
economic performance of the youth fleet
has improved considerably and its
profits are increasing